this episode is sponsored by
curiositystream
and nebula get both for just 15
a year each year various marketing firms
assemble highly publicized lists of the
most
valuable brands in the world this one
brands considers financial factors such
as how much revenue a company generates
as well as subjective measures like
awareness and opinion surveys of the
general consumer public
last year's rankings for example went
pretty much
as you'd expect at the top are amazon
apple microsoft and google below them
are the other iconic global brands like
disney
starbucks and netflix but a few
in particular stand out while they've
scored very highly
precisely for their popularity strangely
there's a very good chance you've never
heard of them
one such company is tencent whose
twitter account has a measly 23 000
followers visa meanwhile despite being a
credit card company
has 383 000. mastercard has 480 000
of course number of twitter followers is
by no means a complete or accurate
picture of a company's popularity
but that's exactly the point tencent is
one of the world's most recognizable
brands
and yet most of the world doesn't even
know what it is
such is the insularity of the chinese
market
there are however many good reasons to
become familiar
at the highest level tencent is one of
the three chinese internet giants
along with baidu and alibaba together
abbreviated as bat headquartered in an
unusually shaped building in shenzhen
across the border from hong kong the
company exists in a chinese
mirror image of silicon valley with
arduous work hours
an intense culture of competition and a
reputation for doing the unconventional
tencent was founded most famously by
pony his nickname
ma whose first major success was qq
a social network which took off in early
internet china
in many ways ma and tencent were simply
in the right place at the right time but
two of its ideas
stand out if not for their originality
certainly for their early application
firstly
rather than rely on advertising for the
majority of its revenue qq helped
pioneer
value added services users could
purchase
virtual goods like customizable avatars
gifts and status symbols secondly
with each subsequent product tencent
never truly started from scratch
it would carry its enormous and
ever-growing user base
from one venture to the next until it
had near monopoly level control
over the world's largest market in 2011
it launched what became its most popular
app ever
the chat application known in english as
wechat
which integrated with qq its momentum
grew dramatically with the introduction
of the now ubiquitous wechat pay
and mini programs which allows users to
install
other apps within the app bypassing the
app store
and ios's rules which apple conveniently
turns a blind eye to
today wechat is called a super app or
the operating system of china
because of its ability to do everything
from act as a wallet
pay rent shop online and much much
more it's over 1.2 billion users
spend four hours a day in the app on
average in china
that's more than american users spend on
all
social media combined with wechat
tencent is like amazon in that it acts
as a gatekeeper of the market
setting prices copying and killing
competitors
and effectively taxing all other
companies
when foreign firms enter china they
inevitably partner with tencent
or die of obscurity and yet
the app is only a relatively small part
of the 10 cent business empire
its seven divisions each compare
favorably
if not embarrass entire other companies
for example its payment services
division is almost as large as paypal
its subscription revenue closely follows
that of netflix
and it makes more from games than sony
or nintendo
outside of china tencent holds a vast
collection of investments
including tesla snap and epic games
the maker of fortnite and the unreal
engine it also
wholly owns riot games the parent of
league of legends
tencent's game store called wii game is
significantly bigger than steam
it's american competitor you could say
that tencent is not
a games company but it is the world's
largest game
company that is also one of its most
long-standing criticisms
that somewhere along the evolution from
chat application
to internet technology social network
game payment service
platform the company lost its soul
some argue it lacks a singular drive
motivation or focus
and is more akin to a boring old
investment fund
tencent is a part owner of so many
hundreds of companies
you've almost certainly unknowingly used
one of its products
but you might ask why any country with
china's diversity of regions
languages and cultures not to mention
its
sheer size would seem to predispose it
to much
competition why is the us home to
facebook twitter
netflix discord instagram and youtube
while
china four times its size home to
effectively
one company to rule them all the answer
is counter-intuitive to almost
everything most people have been taught
about china
in a word non-interference
it's not exactly true that the chinese
government is
overbearing and controlling for foreign
companies
absolutely but in terms of oversight and
industry regulation
china has actually given certain
companies
extraordinary freedom the very
existence of alibaba baidu and tencent
prove china's willingness to tolerate
extreme monopolies when it benefits the
state
broadly speaking large private chinese
corporations
serve three purposes firstly they
elevate the image of chinese
entrepreneurship
and therefore the china brand more
generally
evidence of its transformation into a
moderately prosperous society
in party speak second the success of
domestic companies
comes at the expense of foreign ones to
the very limited extent that western
companies succeed in china
they do so with the express approval and
financial benefit of a chinese
counterpart
this is even legally codified in the way
that foreign firms are required by law
to partner with a local one third
finally and most controversially global
brands provide
china with extra territorial power by
holding majority
or even minority stakes and overseas
companies
china can impose its laws and
sensibilities on the rest of the world
when overseas chinese communities get
their news from wechat
they continue for example to be shaped
by chinese narratives
despite living on australian canadian or
american soil tencent is so colossally
huge
thanks to china's grand political
ambitions
but now having accomplished them the
mood
is changing and no recent event better
represents this
shift than the cancellation of the ant
group ipo
according to reports chairman xi jinping
himself
stopped one of the largest chinese
financial firms from going public
sending a clear message that no company
interest or individual
even the very richest and most
influential is above the law
or party you can watch the full version
of this video
which replaces this section now with an
explanation of what happened to the ant
group
and why it's just the beginning on
nebula
the streaming site i helped create to
give you the very best experience
there are no ads videos are available
early
and you can watch entirely exclusive
original content
we've partnered with curiositystream
home to great documentaries on
technology history and science
like this one about facebook's data
collection so you can get
it and nebula for less than 15
a year sign up with the link in the
description
and watch the extended version of this
video over
on nebula
you